I wanted to be in an organization it
helps to make the world a little bit a
better place to do digital business so
my my kids and my parents when they go
online they are not afraid and you know
they can put the credit card and you
know they can shop and they can should
not be so much afraid that their
information and credentials will be out
there and when I had the chance to join
us a company like that it really really
protects organizations welcome to 20
minute leaders just sit back relax and
learn from the leaders of today it's a
journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today I'm
with yohai Koran a multi-disciplinary
executive with an impressive ability to
innovate and Lead businesses products
and projects He has over 20 years of
experience leading sales Business
Development product management and
innovation in international markets
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to 20 milliliters thank you so
much for being here with me how are you
I'm great thank you Michael for inviting
me and I'm looking forward for an
interesting discussion it'll be an
awesome discussion here there's such a
such a cool
career Journey we read your your buyer
too to the guests already but
you know from from 8200 to to Academia
to entrepreneurship variant
albeit a bunch of different
organizations in between a lot of
organizations in between and and now
um again CEO of a company cyber cyber
intend you're in the Digital Risk
protection and threat intelligence space
and so a lot to uncover and but what I
really want to start uh unconventionally
is is from your I believe your your
first degree in the opening University
is studying history in geography how it
you know connect the dots for me between
Yokai the history and geography major
and Yokai the the Cyber Tourette
entrepreneur
okay when I I like hiking
and traveling since the young age I was
also a
you know the
tour guide even when I was uh you know
even in high school
um
and inside the military service there is
a unique competition maybe only for the
Israeli military which is knowing your
heritage and geography no no it's never
it's called the idiot art yeah and
and I I I was just invited as a young
Soldier and it was instead of uh
um you know cleaning the dishes Duty so
I said let's do it
um and one exam after the other I came
to win this championship for all of the
Israeli Defense Forces so I I was the
champion or the general foreign Israeli
uh military Heritage and history so I
thought even though I was in a very um
very uh I was a condensed military
service not a lot of time I could find a
time to learn and study so I said let's
let's do something interesting with that
I will never be an historian but I like
history so I let's take the time while I
have in the military news the opening
University to actually take some
geography in historical and
archaeological courses and I did so and
actually it was really really uh really
nice and I love it and I recommend for
everyone to take parallel chords and
maybe we can talk about it you know the
words as we continue the discussion have
parallel uh Pathways in your life that
is not only your your main career always
have two or three other things in
parallel and I think for me all over the
years it helped me to connect and give
ideas that are making me a better person
a better manager and better professional
so understanding history makes at the
end of the Cyber Nick and can give you
the the stage later for that it may be
interesting
um
when I won this Championship
um I thought how I can help with my
knowledge also from the University but
from a lot of uh working on my two feet
around the mountains of Israel how I can
help others and I decided to uh to set
up a small website within A200 and said
every weekend a recommendation for uh
for the next hike for the weekend for
everyone yeah and I did it week after
week yeah so they you understand how the
history and geography helped me there
yeah and I extend them to to this video
to this hill etc etc and when I finished
my military service people said you know
what you you must continue with that so
I I set up a my first and uh
you know project which was to set up
purely tiony's uh the I think the number
one website in Israel for a Leisure and
hiking and and trip activities for
people
um
and I started to put it in in the
internet and while I was studying and
while I was working I also uh continue
with this startup I would say and you
can show more about it and how it led to
my position in cybering today I would
love that that would be great let's do
that okay
so
you know what is as any entrepreneur the
goal is to identify a problem
and to bring the solution to this
problem and with A continuous evaluation
process so I found that people do not
know where to go in the weekends right
France you know 20 20 something years
old they want to go and have a nice
weekend in the in the nature but they
don't know where where to go and yeah
all of them has this guidebook so when I
when I did it in 1920 so uh 203 there
was you know those buy books that you
need to buy so I thought there was no
good information in the internet and I
decided to write those recommendations
in in my website and suddenly this
website becomes with uh tens of
thousands of people going every day to
look for ideas so I added legends about
flowers and things that people could
teach their kids while they they hike
and I created maps and and suddenly it
was a big big becoming a business in a
way so I added people who can publish
and advertise a long story short I had
again one of the main or the leading
website in Israel for
um for leisure time and hiking in the
weekends Etc
and I wanted to try to connect it to uh
to business and I uh and I thought if I
have so many people visiting this
website maybe they can also you know buy
hiking equipment
today in Black Friday you know this is
what this is how we show up right the
more than 10 10 years ago it was not the
same uh I didn't want to end the
logistics but like they did Amazon so I
wanted to partner with someone and I met
the LA Mateen uh which is you know
stores and I thought to be their digital
arm and long story short after a few uh
years of working together they decided
to uh to buy TV and and that's what my
first day I would say uh that's awesome
that's great
so you know through this passion of
history and geography I wanted to give
something to society and I volunteered a
lot in you know gave
um tons of my time my wife says it was
like uh it's like she married someone
with a baby from a uh from a different
marriage in the time of love and
investment they put into the early
um but it also taught me business it
taught me internet and taught me
advertisement it taught me how to do
business development and Partnerships
and how to do business and and contracts
Etc and it led me to understand to be a
position of the CEO through this uh you
know cycle of business we took I think
something like six years still today
theol is one of the biggest places in
the website in Israel that you can go
and enjoy a part of the metal
um a small baby which is now almost 19
years old I started this time
it's kind of an amazing feat creating a
product that 90 years later is still
used especially after an m a i mean most
M A's fail right in the integration
phase and and even without that hurdle
building something that people actually
need and actually enjoy using that
sustains a whole you know e-commerce
technological Revolution multiple times
how do you explain that what what you
know what's the magic there that keeps
it alive I'm shocked
first of all Facebook isn't even able to
do what you did
you know I think I have still more
something to learn from Facebook as well
but I would say in the journey uh the
acquiring organization La material I met
you value model which is the founder and
CEO there and I found that his uh a
unique person with very similar DNA to
myself and we became friends
so I didn't sell Tilly to make a bunch
of money and go home I I really thought
it would be a good home they can invest
more efforts into continue growing it
for five or more years
I participated and and helped grow the
business until I thought that they were
really the right people inside and again
it's the the DNA of limited that I think
I gave the extra color that was was
required to get the Boost that I wanted
for a portilli and and originally also
the product was really really good so
when you have this good uh core
um it just stayed and I think still
today if people go to theory.com
um they see trips that I wrote the the
strip guy then and the explanations and
it's still true and people go to another
or to Jerusalem or and and they can
follow my my recommendations of where to
hype and I think it's still relevant
every day that's amazing that's correct
now let's transition to what you're
doing today with cyberant and cyber
security what's what's happening there
what got you into this from an
entrepreneurial perspective and how did
you when and and then we'll dive
specifically a little bit into what
cyberge is doing okay
so I didn't plan to go to side rent I I
in public to bring it to you I decided
to um be in a high ticket because it
would be more more relevant and
effective and using additional talents
that I I thought I had and so I did work
with different companies in product
management and engineering and then I
moved into the business side themselves
and marketing uh give me I would say 360
degrees of how how an organization how
organization works with the different
elements and the parts that need to be
really really effective together and and
one that I called the I got the code
from a Headhunter so the you know we
think it's the right time for you to
become a CEO uh I'm at the board of
directors of cybering with uh we're
looking for CEO for the company I
thought that my background in
intelligence and and cyber is relevant
and they thought probably as well and I
got the position
so and so deciding first of all just you
know a few words on deciding to join as
a CEO of an existing company that's a
it's a it obviously it happens it's it's
not the traditional entrepreneurial
route necessarily it has its you know
benefits and and drawbacks whoa you know
what were the different what was where
was Yokai in that decision-making
process in terms of what you were
prioritizing or or giving up potentially
myself with over the company well for
you what was it like what was it for you
sort of a decision I worked in in a
really good company called Psy uh that
the sales business there and I really
was I was happy and I really appreciate
you know the CEO there Ruby and the rest
of the team but I I felt that I have
their needed experience and abilities
and you know what I learned over the
years to to make the shots myself
um and and this is the difference and
then over there is a CEO you you need to
make the calls you have a very smart
team surrounding you but at the end of
the day the full responsibilities on
your shoulders and I felt that uh I have
the um I would say capabilities to um
to integrate the knitting parts from the
company and and bring some strategy and
some Vision to the organization then I
didn't do it alone I did it with the
rest of the management of cyberant and
with the help of the world of directors
well I felt this is the right time for
me already 20 years experienced covering
different areas I felt this is uh
um the the next natural step for me and
when you get this opportunity to set
yourself it's not very standard uh you
need to think three times before you
pass away of such opportunity it gives
you an experience that you will not get
anywhere even if you do not succeed
still very valuable experience hope you
know I'm happy that I cannot say we have
not succeeded to this point uh so
definitely it was a smart decision
yeah okay well let's talk about what
cybernetis is doing and and maybe in
order to to do that I'd love to get a
little bit of a landscape from U.S to
the the sort of the world that we're
living in in terms of Digital Risk
protection threat intelligence what do
those things actually mean to you and
and we'll take it from there
maybe go one step back and describe we
are living in a digital world uh today
and people and definitely covered did a
big push in working from home and you
know using Cloud environments
and the hackers also see that and it is
become a very lucrative business that I
have a lecture about the the Commerce
behind the darknet and people make a lot
of money and just like in in business
there are people who are you know
looking for big organizations to hack
and they just sell this information
other just develop model it as a service
in in SAS platforms others know how to
execute the text there are really
professionalism within within hackers
group and they exchange information
in a way that there are billions of
dollars everywhere in in this in this
area and the result is exponential
increase in cyber attacks and when you
are in the darkness every day like I am
and my team it is not something which is
in the dreams okay there are millions of
computers being infected every year with
information extracted and just that we
saw what happened in Uber just few
um weeks ago this was a simple mistake
over one of the employees was in the
right position with the right
capabilities on his computer and the
hacker just you know made and made the
right steps there and it happened to
many companies and I wanted to be in an
organization that helps to make the
world a little bit a better place to do
digital business so my my kids and my
parents when they go online they are not
afraid and you know they can put the
credit card and you know they can shop
and they can should not be so much
afraid that their information and
credentials will be out there and when I
had the chance to join us a company like
that it really really protects
organizations yeah I felt you know it's
really fitting to what I would like to
do and when I wake up every day and I
think everyone in cybert we really feel
but at any basis that we stop at X there
are so many how do you how do you make
that how do you get that feeling how do
you create a culture where people you
know know across the culture feel and
resonate with that
you know what I just yesterday I
remember we have a new employee I think
he is less than four weeks in their
company and asked him in the kitchen
yesterday you know how is it going and
he said you know it was glowing and I
said what happened he said yesterday I
already worked for one of the customers
and I found a small piece of you know
trail and I pulled you know the the the
the the Rope or I really call it until I
found the juicy stuff and I found an
attack that is actually currently going
with a very big exposure of a customer
information that you know could be
disaster for this organization and I was
able to identify an alert on time and
they could remediate this problem this
is a feeling of someone with a four
weeks inside break okay so this is this
is not something you know one in a year
this happens every day uh where we are
identifying this uh these problems or
helping to solve them
um I hope I answered the question 100
100 sorry just give me one second where
I just had a something crashed here for
me but I'm gonna maybe maybe it's
exactly what maybe it's exactly what
what we've been talking about if you if
you're if you're looking into a little
bit into into the future you know as an
entrepreneur you know Vision Etc you
know where are we headed in terms of
these threats and the potential
Solutions are we optimistic pessimistic
realistic well what's happening
maybe let me try to answer it from a
different perspective first of all how
how do you stop those uh hackers maybe
to say right this is the questions there
are a few approaches to this one is to
build very high Works internally and
hope the hackers will not never bypass
the awards with everyone that learns
some historical uh military history
knows that the hackers always or the
attacker always find a way to bypass the
lines of Defense so we took the approach
of actually uh trying to identify the
hacker using intelligence capabilities
before they go to their maximum stats of
their of their actions we do that by
scanning the entire internet and looking
from the outside whether there are any
Windows where the hacker can go in
um then in the topic called attack
surface management and we're also
looking at the open deep and dark web
we're looking for Commerce and chatter
between threat actors to see their
intention and information they are
trying to sell and we're also looking
for mistakes people are doing and
uploading source code with you know
credentials into to code repositories
and other places where
this this mistake could be identified by
hackers and you know then they can try
to hack the organization our goal is to
identify that ahead of time and now
starts to your question a game of a cat
mouth you know so how quick are we to
detect the problem and are we able to
tell the organization about it and they
can fix it ahead of time and is this
window which sometimes hours or days or
hours is is effective enough to help the
hackers to help the organization stop
the hackers before they make them make
damage and I think I'm I'm optimistic
because organization first of all I'm
optimistic by nature which is uh very
important for any CEO I believe and that
we look at the future and we are sure
everything is going to be fine but also
we need to be realistic and to plan to
do situations so not everything will be
fine
but we are able to identify that every
day which means our customers see the
value and when they come up to decision
should I pay cyberant again they say yes
I saw what happened last year I would
like to go on my side again and our our
vision today we call it impactful
intelligence and impact in making an
impact on our organization not just
telling you hey there's a problem
actually we want to verify that the
organization that we provide them with
the information of the problem are able
to fix it and quickly so we actually
measure the time it takes to uh to close
the the cycle and we have different
ideas on how to do it faster and faster
and more automated way and I think
organizations today are becoming more
mature I think the the customers of any
company demand cyber security cyber
security is not any longer in most
organizations an expenditure that you
want to minimize people understand this
is
that a mandatory capability and maybe
even a business enabler enabler so
people will say you know I was in in
Bangalore me event yesterday and on
there you know in the two minutes
promotion they did for the bank
um they said we are the best in cyber
security
for them you know cyber security and
information and the confidential
information to protect is something they
put in their advertisement so this is a
business enabler or not so I'm happy to
be in past a part of this transition
where cyber security becomes business
ineva rather than expenditure and you
know we could need to continue and prove
how we actually stop hackers before they
are able to get in
um and as the exponential rise in
attacks continues to to happen I think
we're we're in a good position
I love it that's really really cool
now my favorite question before I say
goodbye your biggest moment of delight
if you had to look at your day-to-day
your journey what is sort of the you
know the those moments of delight that
make it all worth to make make it an
inspiring life for you to live
um not that easy question because I
think it should not be just one moment
moment I feel I have many of those every
day an example of an employee that says
you know I'm happy I'm cybering or I
feel I feel good I'm here
or a customer that tells me
um
you know what
thank you I sleep better at night when I
when I have you right this is this is
everything we're doing and you know
every there are so many problems in
battles on a day-to-day that things
doesn't work well and you have issues
and you need to solve them and there's
those moment of of you know happiness
from from people that you invest with
employees and customers this is a two
things are more critical for an
organization
and I think when I get this feedback
he's happy but I also I'm going to give
a different perspective also I I I
started to be a pilot so I'm a pilot
today I always told you need to have
private things in life right
um so I wasn't there with my son it's
also something new so
this is this is part of what I'm trying
to do have multiple things that you know
interconnect at the end of the day
I love it I love it well I'm gonna see
you I'm gonna see you in the air and
pilot myself as well and so it's a I'm
wishing you best of luck with cyberant
and I love the the insights and and
awesome story you know all the way going
back to history in geography I think
that's just you know really embodying
the the true Spirit of you know the true
entrepreneurial spirit and in the most
on the most fundamental form of it so
really thank you very much you hi
wishing you best of luck looking forward
to keeping in touch and uh looking
forward to continuing from the side so
again thank you for fasting me thanks
Michael
[Music]